declaration of result of whole election
of a member of parliament for the
Ipswich constituency Thursday 8 15 2017
I Sarah Lynn Randall barber returning
officer for the Ipswich constituency
hereby declared that the total number of
votes given to each candidate was as
follows Armstrong Charlotte Green Party
candidate 800 reporting gold common
Antony UK Independence Party you kick
1372 gumma Benedict Michael the
Conservative Party candidate 23,000 393
hi julain Trent Adrienne James Liberal
Democrats 1187 Martin Alexander Gordon
Labour Party twenty four thousand twenty
four thousand two hundred and twenty
four tibay David haboob independent 121
therefore I give public notice that
Alexander Gordon Martin is Julie elected
as Member of Parliament the Ipswich
constituency
[Applause]
the total number of votes cast across if
switch at the UK parliamentary election
on the 8th of June 2017 was fifty 1234 a
67.7% turnout the number of ballot
papers rejected was 100 the ballot
papers were rejected for the following
reasons
one ballot paper rejected because they
did not bear the official mark 23 ballot
papers were rejected because votes were
given for more than one candidate 0
ballot papers were rejected because
there was something written or marked on
the ballot paper by which the voter
could be identified 76 ballot papers
were rejected because they were unmarked
or void for uncertainty therefore I like
to invite on UMP to say three words
I'd like to start by thanking the police
the returning officer the polling
station staff the counting staff and
everybody else who's been involved in
this election which has been carried out
carefully properly and leave legally I'd
also like to thank the other political
parties involved this was a very good
election campaign conducted in a
civilized way with a great degree of
sense and a clear focus on the issues
involved rather than the personalities I
would also like to thank the local media
who have again focused on the issues and
the people of issues which you have
thought about the issues that they
wanted to vote on it has been fair that
is being calm and for myself it has been
a good deal of enthusiasm that I have
seen in the town which has really made
me feel that people have for the first
time in a long time really throwing
themselves into why we're having an
election why we should be thinking about
the issues that we have had in front of
ourselves and I think that contrasts
with some of the treatment from the
national press it is the issues that
have one the issues of housing of pay of
the Health Service of Education people
can see these things that are having a
real effect on their lives and when they
look at what makes a difference to them
rather than what is written on the front
of their national newspaper I think that
they are more capable of making a
sensible decision about how to vote I've
been visiting virtually every part of
its which during the course of this
six-week campaign and talk
two people from every walk of life and
it strikes me that far too many
politicians and I'm talking about people
in my own party as well and too many of
the rest of us here as well have lost
touch with too many of the lives that
too many people lead we need to
reconnect with those people we all need
to make everyone feel that they are part
of a society that works for them we need
to deal with the sense of alienation
that some people in our society have we
need to create a united dipswitch
and who knows maybe we can be a beacon
to help other people see that they need
to create united societies in their own
towns as well thank you very much
[Applause]